el ministro de asuntos exteriores de
españa josé manuel álvarez convocó al
embajador ruso en madrid este miércoles
para trasladar el rechazo por la
decisión del presidente ruso vladimir
putin de reconocer unilateralmente la
independencia de las regiones ucranianas
de donets y lugansk pese a que españa y
ucrania están en extremos opuestos de
europa el ministro español reiteró el
compromiso del gobierno para seguir
trabajando en una vía diplomática o de
disuasión que ponga freno al conflicto
entre moscú y kiev sin embargo álvarez
recomendó a los españoles que abandonen
ucrania y desaconsejó los viajes al país
del este reconoció que esta crisis
podría marcar un antes y un después en
la historia del continente y pidió
unidad ante lo que él considera la mayor
amenaza a la seguridad de europa en las
últimas décadas el presidente del
gobierno español pedro sánchez acudirá
el jueves a la cumbre de emergencia
convocada en bruselas por el presidente
del consejo europeo para analizar la
situación en ucrania y aunque la
presencia militar española en la región
está limitada a algunos efectivos en
países cercanos esto podría cambiar ya
que recordemos españa será el país
anfitrión de la cumbre de la otan a
finales de junio algo que podría
presionar al gobierno de pedro sánchez a
aportar más efectivos a la región la
opinión pública española está bastante
dividida al respecto un 52% de los
españoles no apoyaría una intervención
militar directa de españa en la región
mientras que un 48% sí estaría de
acuerdo